so I've noticed in when I've lived in
places rented or owned didn't matter
then if there were part of the place if
there was a part of the place that I
hadn't attended to whatever that might
mean it might meant cleaned it might
have meant fixed but it certainly meant
at least thoroughly investigated then
that was chaos it was like it was it was
like the desert that part that's that's
a way of thinking about it it wasn't
mine even if I owned it wasn't mine I
had to interact with it before it became
mine and I had to interact with it and I
had to put it in order and then it
became mine and then and then to the
degree that it became mine and was in
order then I was also put in order now
you know that because you go into places
that make you uncomfortable and maybe
it's your own house it's highly probable
it's highly probable I you know I walk
into well Chinese doctors do this
traditional Chinese doctors they go into
place people's place and they they
diagnose their health conditions on the
on the balance of yin and yang chaos an
order they walked into a house if this
is easy to do you walk into a house
there's too much chaos hey you can
detect that in no time flat everything
is out of order
and chaotic you don't even want to be
there you certainly don't want to open
the refrigerator that's for sure and
there are things that should have been
done years ago everywhere and every one
of those things is a fight that hasn't
happened and something that's being
avoided and you can't even walk in there
and maintain your health as soon as you
walk in there you're sicker than you
were when you were outside and that's
one sort of place and then another sort
of place is you go in you look at the
living room and the person has vacuumed
the living room rug and the lines that
were vacuumed are parallel to one
another and the and the furniture is
covered with plastic and you get a glass
of water and then just as you're going
to set it down on the coffee table
the person rushes over and puts a
coaster underneath it and everything in
that house says to you that it would be
a lot more perfect in that house if you
were either not there or dead and that's
there and that's the message that the
whole house is blasting at you and if
you happen to live there then you're
going to be sick and what you're going
to be sick from is too much order and in
the other house you're going to be sick
from too much chaos
and so when you interact with a house
the unexplored parts are the chaos that
have that parts that you have not yet
contended with are the chaos that has
not yet been transformed by your
embodied logos action into habitable
territory and it does not belong to you